Still, considering some different chemo therapies as an adjunctive chemo that they're recommended.
I have asked my ecologist to advise me given the risk profile, which what is three out of five
survival and recurrence risks percent wise if I just did observation and no chemo. I've had three to five
year. Sorry. Okay. Three to five year survival. So far, they've not answered that question. Not sure.
It exists presently oncologist and I looked on pub them for papers. I can only find chemo comparison
results. I would agree. You do have to search hard and long to find, you know, survival rates for
chemo versus not doing anything because those studies are done, especially in different countries,
but they get buried and especially in Google. They don't want you to find those studies if they
do exist, especially if they don't have the outcome that you want. And the truth is is that you have
to find a study about it because, you know, okay, let's say you're on a, so, okay, so you're going
to an oncologist. They're keeping records on you, but the truth is that they're not like, you know,
sending those records to some sort of database. Now, I think those exist, but the chance that,
you know, your oncologist is doing that is probably pretty slim. So when they give you these numbers,
would you Google a number like, what's the five year survival rate for painkriotic cancer,
and you get 7%, five year survival rate painkriotic cancer? Where, you know, you have to have
question like, where do they come up with this number? And the answer is through a collaboration of
some studies, probably, because I'll give it to you every painkriotic cancer patient is not
is certainly not put in some database. And the date of their cancer diagnosis is then
timed out over five years. And if they live five years, then it's going to the database that
that's improved that. It's just not that sophisticated in record keeping across the country.
And certainly, if a person doesn't follow through, how many times change oncologists and things,
it's just a way that data is kept. And if a person doesn't follow through with everything with
the oncologist, let's say they go do an alternative thing. What do you think they're calling people five
years after the, you know, their date of diagnosis and said, hey, are you still alive? Because we want
to register you as a survivor, five year survival rate to increase the survival rate. And that's
just not being done. So, you know, that's why a lot of authors have called those numbers really
rubber numbers because, you know, the thing about statistics is that statistically you could make
statistics, you know, look any way you want them to look. So, yeah, it's hard. Sorry, let's keep
going. Every single year at the European study from 2015 that shows the findings we analyzed data
from four eligible trials, including data from 1196 patients with stage two or three disease.
And double resection two were located. So, they give some data to say put into the information
of who they qualified in the study. We found those significant differences. Overall, survival
rate patients who received a genitive chemotherapy, those who underwent an observation, we need no
chemotherapy. Well, you could see why you probably had to dignify that stuff, yeah. So, yeah, you
started to know whether this applies exactly to your case. The thing is, it's really hard to know
what applies because all these are these 1196 people are just all different people. You don't
know how many of those people did some alternative things too. You know, how many people were really
to try to change their diet. You don't know how many people were had, you know, multiple cold
morbidities along with it. It's just, it's just really hard to make decision making health care
decisions based upon the data that's out there. You just try to, try to weigh through the muck
and then you, that's why I always say you have to have a relationship with God that you can just go
and say, Lord, what am I supposed to do here? Here's the data, what am I supposed to do? I mean,
with my cancer, you know, they're just finished a successful, fantastic study, 10 patients and they thought
it was great because two of them lived in extra eight months or something doing this chemotherapy.
I was like, okay, well, that stinks. I mean, this was their success study. That was on the first page
of Google by mail. Well, forget it was easy decision-making process, but it's harder decision-making
process when the data is much more smeared. And it's, I get it, it's difficult. It gets down to you.
You have peace in your heart about doing that because, you know, I mean, I just, I think somebody
shared with me a video of a must have been an alternative practitioner who was just saying awful
things about chemotherapy that nobody should do chemotherapy. Well, I totally disagree with that
position too because I mean, come on. Lots of people, their lives have been saved by doing surgery
or chemotherapy or radiation. You can argue with that data that's out there, but lots of people have
been killed by a two. Oh my gosh, so what am I supposed to do? Well, you got to make your own decisions
in all this and you have to have peace about those decisions when you go into it. You have to know that
there's risk involved with anything, but there's risk involved with not doing that to thing two. So
we all are living our lives in risk. There's risks driving home from the office. There's risks in,
in, you know, just in, in living in this world. And we have to take the most calculated risk based upon
the knowledge that we can find out there and know that there's a lot of bias in the data.
Know that there's a lot of incorrect data. The sixth and we all go through COVID, which is a
complete scam at the end degree. And we've learned that we can't necessarily trust people that
we're supposed to, we have been taught as a child to put our trusted. So we do need to find, you know,
out information as much as possible in ourselves and weigh things out. But I don't think that
all chemo is bad. I certainly don't think that all surgery is bad or radiation is bad. I think
there's a place for all of those things. And we just try to, you know, like you're doing, Ed, you're
digging into the research out there and trying to find some information and go, gee, what should I do?
But it ultimately boils down to, you know, using wisdom, which is, you know, if you're gaining
knowledge, you then try to decipher that knowledge and ask for wisdom of how to utilize that
knowledge. And then you have to find peace in your heart that that's the right, that is the right
thing for you to do.